[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video i'm going to be
discussing a topic that was requested by
you guys
in the comments section i always read
the comments so if you want a topic made
then be sure to request it the next one
might be yours
in this video i'm going to be discussing
severus snape
lily evans james potter and one of the
purest forms of magic
the patronus the patronus charm is
famous
for its representation of light
happiness and
purity and it's produced when a witch or
wizard cast the spell
expecto patronum there are two types of
patronus charms
corporeal and incorporeal and the type
that the witcher wizard casts
will depend on their experience or
preference the more basic form of the
spell
is the incorporeal patronus which
assumes no animal form
and simply resembles a burst of white
vapour or smoke
and the more advanced form of the spell
is the conjuring of a corporeal patronus
which i'll be focusing on in this video
we see many of our favorite characters
in the books and films
achieve the notable and complicated
ability to cast a corporeal patronus
and this can largely be attributed to
the guidance provided by harry
in dumbledore's army along with those in
dumbledore's army
various other talented witches wizards
and professors
are also able to cast such a charm
harry's parents
included despite snape's dubious past as
a death eater
it has been stated that he was the only
death eater that was ever able to
produce one
it's widely thought that conjuring a
patronus when you're evil
is impossible but that's not entirely
accurate it's just
risky in the story of rexidian the first
evil wizard ever to attempt the spell
he ended up being devoured by maggots
which shot out of his wand
this doesn't exactly make it inviting
but what exhidion lacked
were the necessary happy memories that
you need in order to cast
such a spell despite snape's
questionable history
and the hardships that he endured
throughout his life he was still always
able to think back
to happier times his childhood in coke
worth with lily evans
we know that james potter's patronus was
a stag and we know that lily's was a doe
and it's revealed to us in an iconic
exchange between dumbledore and snape in
the deathly hallows
that snape's patronus is a doe as well
but this is touching
severus said dumbledore seriously have
you grown to care for the boy
after all for him shouted snape expecto
patronum
from the tip of his wand burst the
silver doe she landed on the office
floor
bounded once across the office and
soared out of the window
dumbledore watched her fly away and as
her silvery glow faded
he turned back to snape and his eyes
were full of tears
after all this time always said snape
this scene depicts dumbledore's genuine
surprise at snape's patronus form
a doe as he never understood the true
level of commitment that snape felt
toward lily
delmodo never suspected snape's
motivations had changed but when he says
after all this time to snape it paints a
clear picture of just how much snape
cared for lily
dumbledore knew that lily potter's
patronus was also a doe
and it's well known that when you well
and truly love someone that your
patronus can change to match theirs
the patronus charm is a powerful piece
of magic that expresses the true nature
of the caster
and can be influenced by significant
events or people in one's life
you can't choose your patronus or change
it willfully and the fact that snape's
patronus was still a doe
matching lily after all that time was
representative of the fact that he truly
loved lily
and that his feelings for her hadn't
weakened over the years
lily potter had been dead for 17 years
but his love for her was still strong
however one thing that i'm sure a lot of
you have been wondering is what would
snape's patronus
before it changed to a doe if the
patronus changes to match the one that
you love
then i think that it would be reasonable
to assume that snape had another
patronus animal
at one point or another one that was
independent from lily
however here's the thing snape always
loved lily
from the moment they met in childhood
they spent so much time together in
their formative years
in the town of cokeworth and created
such a bond that i think their patronus
forms were perhaps influenced
by one another it's untelling when your
corporeal patronus form is actually
determined or
assigned to a witch or wizard but given
that it
is influenced by significant events or
people it's reasonable to assume
that it's not a predefined thing for
this reason
i think that from the moment that snape
and lily met they were destined to have
the same patronus
though there is a possibility that snape
had his own patronus form independent
from lilly before his changed
i personally believe that his patronus
was always a doe
one theory that i have surrounding this
is that it was actually lilly's patronus
that changed
rather than snapes out of her love for
snape
rather than the other way around though
they went in very different directions
later in life
they were very close for very many years
and there was certainly a point in time
in which james potter was not even
remotely on lily's radar
this opens up a whole other can of worms
but it's an interesting thought
so if snape's patronus wasn't always a
doe
if snape had his own patronus form at
one point or another what would it have
been
i have a few theories for this it's well
known that the possibilities for what a
patronus can actually be
are fairly endless though magical
creatures such as dragons
thestrals and phoenixes are exceedingly
rare no reliable system
for predicting the form of an
individual's patronus has ever been
found
although the great 18th century
researcher of charms professor catholic
spangle
set forth certain principles that are
widely accepted as true
the patronus asserted spangle represents
that which is hidden
unknown but necessary within the
personality here
says bengal is the explanation for the
appearance of patronuses in forms that
their casters might not expect
for which they have never felt a
particular affinity or in rare cases
even recognized this doesn't exactly
help us to narrow down what snape's
patronus could have originally been
but if we dig deep into snape's
character and personality traits
i think that we can derive some options
one of the things about snape that
stands out to me most is his lifelong
devotion to lily
a kind of loyalty that would have been
ingrained in his very persona
based on this trait there are a few
animals that come to mind
number one turtle dove turtle doves are
common throughout europe
and have become a symbol of eternal love
notably featured in william
shakespeare's poems
and as a pair in the 12 days of
christmas their mating for life has been
the reason they've become associated
with love
although their mournful voice also has
influenced their place in culture
the turtledove is also one of the
animals that will remain alone if their
mate dies
number two prairie vole when a male
prairie vault chooses a female
that is the female that it will remain
with for the rest of its life
if the female dies the male will not
look for a new mate
prairie voles are rarely seen because
they live in underground burrows
and are usually nocturnal rarely seen
lifelong commitment
underground burrow sounds like snape to
me number three
black vulture black vultures are quite
physically intimidating
and at first glance may not immediately
appear to be good representations of
love and romance
however the black vulture is actually
quite an amorous creature
and once they mate they're made for life
never searching for another partner
i feel that the physical stature of the
black vulture particularly resonates
with snape
number four swans swans are probably the
animal
most commonly associated with love a
reputation garnered by the heart shape
the couple's form
with their necks like the other animals
above they're mate for life
and remain alone after their mate dies
though commonly white
some swans can actually have black
plumage which i think would be more than
fitting for snape
i don't think that any of the options
above are necessarily more fitting than
the others but i am inclined to believe
that some kind of bird patronus would be
most fitting as he is one of the only
known witches and wizards
with the ability to fly what do you guys
think
was snape's patronus or was a doe if it
wasn't what could it have been what are
your thoughts on the animals that i
theorized
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you